désormais gentil avec les gens disent
c'est avec les étrangers qui veulent
travailler en France respecter nos
règles parler notre langue être amoureux
notre drapeau le concept c'est très
pragmatique c'est de mettre en
corrélation des gens qui recherchent un
emploi qui ont des compétences avec les
emplois disponibles et à pourvoir et
être méchant avec les méchants c'est à
dire que nous devons ne pas accepter que
quelqu'un qui ne veut pas s'intégrer qui
ne respecte pas nos règles qui commet
des axes de délinquance ne doit pas
rester sur le sol national idée géniale
trouver par les deux ministres on va
régulariser des étrangers en situation
irrégulière entrer illégalement sur le
territoire au motif qu'il pourrait
pourvoir des métiers en tension voilà
donc c'est une forme de supercherie
derrière les mots il faut préciser la
pensée il s'agit d'une régularisation
massive j'y suis tout à fait défavorable
et restaurateurs ferment des tables ou
ferme le restaurant faute de manoeuvre
les agriculteurs ne récoltent pas leurs
fruits sautent de manœuvre il y a quand
même un problème donc je pense qu'il y a
aussi d'autres qui doivent être
nécessaires notamment celles de
l'assurance chômage je pense qu'il vaut
mieux demain travailler à faire en sorte
que nos propres concitoyens reviennent
vers le chemin du travail que de
solutionner le problème par
l'immigration enfin l'idée ça quand
j'étais premier j'ai dit que je trouvais
que c'était une bonne idée je pense que
on peut en effet utiliser au mieux les
compétences d'un certain nombre
d'étrangers qui sont en France ou qui
veulent venir en France et des
compétences dont on a besoin on voit
qu'on a un marché du travail tendu
actuellement le secteur de l'hôtellerie
restera Sion et celui qui dispose du
plus de postes vacants avec au total
29107 emplois disponibles suivi du
domaine du BTP c'est d'ailleurs ce qu'on
fait les restaurateurs ce qu'on fait les
hôteliers ils ont fait passer des
augmentations de salaire pour que leurs
activités soient plus attractive et puis
en dernier lieu peut venir la solution
de l'immigration de travail mais vous
voyez que je la mets comme la dernière
solution je vois le message qui sera
envoyé c'est-à-dire c'est un énorme
panneau mis sur la France qui indique
très clairement venez de manière irré
venait de manière illégale j'ai pas
d'une régularisation massive c'est du
cas par cas c'est de l'étude de dossier
il faudra pouvoir prouver d'une
ancienneté sur le territoire de
l'exercice d'un métier apparaissant sur
la liste des métiers en tension et je le
dis tout de suite avec toutes les
l'amitié et l'estime que j'ai pour
l'ensemble des responsables de
l'économie ce n'est pas le patronat qui
fait la loi voilà et j'avais cru
comprendre d'ailleurs que le
gouvernement n'était pas sur cette ligne
là je suis pas là pour expliquer comment
je vis une situation
il y a un certain nombre de plaintes qui
ont été déposés il y a des magistrats
qui instruent le collectif dernière
rénovation avait tenté de bloquer la
place de la Concorde un groupe qui
milite pour la conservation d'un
amendement accordant 12 milliards
d'euros pour la rénovation thermique et
d'ailleurs elle le sait très bien et
elle le dit à chaque fois qu'elle
évoquait un sujet une décision à prendre
je l'ai mise en œuvre
à chaque fois à chaque fois donc vous
n'avez pas négligé ces avertissements
absolument pas et elle le sait
parfaitement d'ailleurs et voilà il
s'agisse juste de rénover des logements
et on a des quart
s de s'empêcher de dire que c'est
important mais vraiment là le pouvoir
est en train de perdre son sang-froid
j'étais le chef du gouvernement
et j'assume toutes les responsabilités
prises par l'ensemble des membres de mon
gouvernement et je vais vous dire Thomas
Soto c'est ça être un chef alors quel
autre lieu que cette cour carrée
entouré de chef-d'oeuvre millénaire et
de génie éternel
et de ses amis
de tant de talents contemporains
pour lui faire cortège il y a quelques
semaines cet Australien se lance dans
une exploration nocturne à la recherche
d'un nouveau trésor soudain alors qu'ils
scout le sol à l'aide de sa lampe torche
il distingue sous une fine couche de
poussière et de sable comme un morceau
de verre cassé c'est une pure
coïncidence une oeuvre de Pierre soulage
et mise aux enchères aujourd'hui à
Neuilly-sur-Seine par la maison à gut-il
s'agit d'un tableau de
1980 une huile sur toile intégralement
noir naturellement le caillou est en
fait un saphir XXL à l'état brut de 834
carats une trouvaille exceptionnelle
estimée à 12500 dollars australiens soit
environ 8000 euros